ZDF heute live schön dass ihr heute mit
dabei seid wir wollen heute über das
Thema künstliche Intelligenz sprechen
beim Thema KI da müssen wahrscheinlich
viele von euch jetzt an Unternehmen wie
open ai mit Chat GPT denken das
Unternehmen sorgt aktuell ganz schön für
Schlagzahlen am Freitag musste der Chef
gehen dazu gleich mehr bei uns an KI
made in Germany denken aber
wahrscheinlich wohl die wenigsten
verpennt Deutschland da gerade etwas die
Bundes Regierung will das zumindest
ändern auf ihrem digitalgipfel in Jena
mit Bundesverkehrsminister Volker
Wissing der auch für digitales zuständig
ist diskutieren rund 100 Personen aus
Politik Wirtschaft Wissenschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft über die digitale
Transformation der Umgang mit KI sei
entscheidend für die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und den Wohlstand
in Deutschland so wising in Jena heute
eine KI Hoffnung aus Deutschland ist
Alef Alpha erst Anfang November hat das
Unternehmen aus Heidelberg etwa 500
Millionen Dollar eingesammelt und muss
seitdem als echte Konkurrenz zu
amerikanischen ki-modellen gesehen
werden ich kann gleich sprechen mit dem
CEO und Mitgründer von Alf Alpha Jonas
andrulis hier im Stream ja wo steht der
KI Standort Deutschland wie können sich
Unternehmen aus Deutschland gegenüber
der Konkurrenz aus den USA und auch aus
China behaupten und warum braucht
Deutschland überhaupt eigene unternehmen
das frage ich gleich auch die Ökonomin
Professorin Ulrike Malmendier die als
Wirtschaftsweise auch die deutsche
Bundesregierung berht eure Fragen und
Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr wie immer
sehr gerne direkt hier im Chat stellen
oder ihr schickt sie uns per Mail an die
Mailadresse
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche
dann so viele von euren Fragen und
Gedanken wie möglich hier im Stream
unterzubringen wir wollen jetzt ich habe
es gerade schon einmal kurz gesagt zu
Beginn erstmal auf die aktuellen
Meldungen schauen der Chat GPT
Entwickler open ai hat gerade ein
ziemlich turbulentes Wochenende hinter
sich am Freitag wurde open ai Chef Sam
Altman rausgeworfen am Wochenende wurde
dann diskutiert und spekuliert ob er
möglicherweise zurückkommt heute wurde
dann bekannt dass Altman zu Microsoft
wechselt zusammen mit anderen open ai
Mitarbeitern Sam Altman soll bei
Microsoft ein KI Forschungsteam leiten
ja welche Auswirkung hat das für den
Standort Deutschland darüber kann ich
jetzt sprechen mit dem Mitgründer und
CEO von Alf Alpha Jonas andrulis der mir
jetzt zugeschaltet ist hallo Herr
andrulis hallo schönen Abend also sie
sind studierter Wirtschaftsingenieur sie
haben Berufserfahrung z.B bei
Beratungsfirmen gesammelt sind dann 2016
in Silicon Valley gegangen zu Apple für
3 Jahre und dann zurückgekommen nach
Deutschland um Alif Alpha zu gründen ihr
wohl größter Konkurrent open ai steckt
gerade ich habe es gesagt in der
schweren Krise wie nehmen sie die
Entwicklung wie nehmen sie das was da
gerade passiert
war ja das ist unglaublich turbulent und
die Ursache lässt sich finden in der
Struktur open ai und Microsoft haben
eine besondere Struktur open ai gehört
offiziell einer Stiftung man erinnert
sich open ai war damals gegründet als
als nonprofit als als gemeinnützige
Organisation mit dem Ziel KI transparent
und für alle Menschen zur Verfügung zu
stellen und durch die Zusammenarbeit mit
Microsoft hat sich haben sie sich davon
immer weiter entfernt ja mittlerweile
gibt die Technologie nicht mehr
transparent zur Verfügung gestellt und
kommerzielle Interessen werden immer
stärker und diese die die Absetzung von
Sam Oldman ist genau aus diesem
Spannungsfeld
entstanden ist das was ich habe es
gerade gesagt das ist natürlich auch aus
ihrer Perspektive ein Konkurrent der da
jetzt in der Krise steckt nützt Ihnen
das
was na ja Microsoft ist ja das powerhaus
dahinter und wenn Sam Oldman plus ein
paar der sehr erfahrenen Konkurrenten zu
Microsoft gehen dann werden die da damit
nicht groß Bremsen
ist es aktuell schon so in den Verträgen
microsoft hat volle kommerzielle Rechte
an den Modellen das heißt die können
dort direkt weitermachen müssen
vielleicht noch ein bisschen Daten
sammeln die sie nicht im gleichen Maße
haben aber das zeigt eigentlich nur wie
absolut entschlossen Microsoft ist in
dieser Technologie für diese
industrielle Revolution zu dominieren
Herr Andris dann lassen Sie uns gerne
einmal über Ihr Unternehmen sprechen und
damit wir jetzt alle wissen worüber wir
gleich reden stellen uns meine Kollegen
Luisa Huben und Jan Frederik Fischer das
Unternehmen Alf Alpha einmal kurz
vor zusammenfassen was auf diesen 100
Seiten steht eine Aufgabe die sonst
eigentlich Stunden dauert doch dank
ki-assistent brauchen sie in Stuttgarts
Ministerium dafür künftig nur nur noch
wenige Sekunden F1 kann Texte
zusammenfassen und auch bei der
Recherche zu unterschiedlichen Themen
unterstützen beispielsweise wenn ich
mich frag wie steht die Landesregierung
zum Thema künstliche Intelligenz kann
ich F13 fragen was bereits dazu
beispielsweise in landtagsdrucksachen
veröffentlicht wurde das Besondere an
F13 User können zu jeder Zeit
nachvollziehen woher das Programm seine
Informationen nimmt genau damit will der
Anbieter Alf Alpha rund um CEO Jonas
andrulis pun seine ki-chmiede spricht
vor allem Unternehmen und Verwaltung mit
sensiblen Daten an die eigenserstellten
Sprachprogramme greifen auf ausgewählte
Quellen der Kunden zu diesen
transparenten Ansatz will auch das Land
badenwürttenberg fördern unterstützt das
Unternehmen und ist an der Finanzierung
eines Innovationszentrums in halbronn
beteiligt es soll das größte Europas
werden doch KI aus dem länle kann das
wirklich klappen auf der forschungsseite
sind wir dann noch voll mit dabei nicht
äh die amerikanischen Konzerne sind ja
mehr Kunden getrieben jetzt wir haben
Industrie die meisten Daten werden ja in
der Industrie generiert und da haben wir
die Möglichkeit in die Champions League
aufzusteigen also es ist noch nicht
aller Tage Abend doch im Vergleich ist
klar die Big Player aus den USA oder
China konnten zuletzt deutlich mehr Geld
einsammeln das zeigt der Blick auf die
größten Finanzierungsrunden allein open
ai kam Anfang des Jahres etwa 10
Milliarden US-Dollar auch Unternehmen
aus China und Frankreich verbuchten in
der Vergangenheit große Investments
immerhin Alef Alpha bekam jüngst eine
halbe Milliarde doch reicht das wirklich
aus um sich international zu
behaupten Herr andrud ist eine halbe
Milliarde 500 Milliarden Dollar konnten
500 Millionen Dollar so ist es richtig
konnten sie Einsammeln von Investoren
darunter Bosch SAP und die schwarzgruppe
mit Mark wie Lidl und Kaufland um eine
andere Hausnummer zu geben wir haben
gerade das Ranking gesehen allein
microsoft hat open ai 1 Milliarden
Dollar gegeben an investment reichen
diese 500 Millionen Dollar aus um
irgendwas zu bewegen bei
ihnen das Geld 500 Millionen das ist
genug für uns für den nächsten Schritt
wird das bis in alle Ewigkeiten genügen
nee muss es aber ja auch gar nicht viel
kritischer und deswegen bin ich so froh
dass wir diese Partner schwarzgruppe
Bosch SAP auch HPE dass wir diese
Partner gewinnen konnten ist die
Kommerzialisierung die Anwendung der
Technologie denn wir sind ein paar KI
Nerds also selbst wenn wir jetzt dreimal
so groß werden dann sind wir immer noch
ein kleines KI Forschungsteam das heißt
entscheidend für diese für dass wir uns
als Deutschland als Europa in dieser
industrialen Revolution behaupten können
ist die Technologie auf die Straße zu
bekommen dafür hat open ai Microsoft
gehabt und wir haben dafür jetzt auch
Partner mit dem Unterschied dass unsere
Partner voll auf Souveränität auf
Transparenz setzen und ähm unsere
strategische Unabhängigkeit nicht äh
gefährdet haben und auch nicht
eingeschränkt haben sie sagen der
nächste Schritt also ihre Technologie
wie sie gerade sagten auf die Straße zu
bringen wie konkret muss man sich das
vorstellen wie soll das
aussehen ja so wie mit F13 F13 ist ein
tolles Beispiel das ist eine frühe
Version also Version 0.1 die jetzt schon
viel kann jetzt schon von knapp 400.000
Menschen genutzt wird aber wir müssen
natürlich und da gehe ich wieder zurück
also was hier passiert ist eine
industrielle Revolution alle
Wissensarbeit alle Menschmaschine
Zusammenarbeit kann jetzt eben neu
gedacht werden besser gedacht werden und
diese Technologie das Potenzial sicher
und und skalierend in die Wirtschaft zu
bringen das braucht unheimlich viel Idee
und und Wissen Erfahrung die wir alleine
eben nicht haben könen deswegen brauchen
wir viele Partner was man aber wirklich
jetzt erwarten kann ist dass alles was
vor einem Bildschirm sitzend gemacht
wird das wird sich jetzt in den nächsten
Jahren schnell verändern und dadurch
entsteht eine ganz neue Form der der
Büroarbeit wir haben es gerade in dem
Beitrag von meinen beiden kollegenin
jetzt schon einmal ungefähr gesehen was
was hinter ihrer Technologie steckt wenn
man das aber wenn ich sie das noch
einmal bitten darf mir einmal zu
erklären uns zu erklären wo ist
sozusagen der grundlegende Unterschied
zu dem was man jetzt vielleicht schon
kennt aus ich glaube viele von uns haben
chatgpt auch schon mal genutzt wo genau
ist der Unterschied zu ihrer
Technologie also es gibt zwei
wesentliche Unterschiede der eine ist
wir richten uns nicht an den
Endverbraucher ja wir Chat gbt ist super
geeignet wenn man irgendwie die
Hausaufgaben der Kinder machen will oder
wenn man ein Gedicht zum Geburtstag der
Oma schreiben will unsere Mission ist
wie können wir die komplexesten und
kritischen Wertschöpfungsprozesse der
Welt unterstützen also also im
Gesundheitswesen klar Verwaltung haben
wir gesehen aber auch für große
Finanzinstitute und da haben wir eigene
Technologie eigene Forschung entwickelt
und sind aktuell das einzige Team auf
der Welt was in der Lage ist die
Herkunft die genaue Herkunft und
potenzielle Konflikte und Miss und
Widersprüche in Informationen sichtbar
zu machen und dadurch ermöglichen wir
das den menschlichen Experten
Verantwortung zu übernehmen denn gerade
für die Kunden für die Industrien in
denen wir unterwegs sind da ist es
einfach nicht ausreichend zu sagen ah
der Chatbot hat hat so gesagt das wird
schon
stimmen sie haben wir diesen nächsten
Schritt wie Sie es nennen jetzt auch
schon beschrieben wie welchen welchen
Zeithorizont bzw welche Erfolgschancen
malen sie sich da derzeit
aus wir müssen Gas geben wir sind haben
sie vorhin schon richtig gesagt im
Beitrag
die uskonkurrenz ist uns einen Schritt
voraus aber wie auch der Herr
Ministerpräsident gesagt hat unsere
Forschung ist exzellent wir sind hier in
Heidelberg sind wir umgeben von ein paar
der besten Universitäten der Welt und es
war historisch eigentlich immer so dass
Deutschland dass Europa in der Forschung
excellent war und Geld verdient haben
dann andere damit und und da müssen wir
jetzt schnell Gas geben denn natürlich
ist ja nicht nur Microsoft das ist ja
auch Google auch Meta auch andere haben
erkannt dass die weichen die wir jetzt
stellen dass die entscheiden werden wie
die Zukunft aussieht und W WN wir es
jetzt nicht schaffen schnell genug mit
unseren Partnern diese Technologie in
die Breite zu bringen und dran zu
bleiben was Forschung angeht dann sieht
sieht schlecht aus aber eben damit mit
den Partnern mit dem der Ausstattung
finanziell haben wir eine echte Chance
okay das wäre nämlich meine Frage
gewesen der bitcomin Präsident Ralf
Wintergerst hat gesagt das Rennen um die
KI das ist noch nicht zu Ende wenn ich
ihn jetzt richtig zugehört habe dann
teilen Sie diese Einschätzung richtig
aber wir spielen Klassenerhalt ja also
es ist nicht so dass wir da eine
komfortable Position haben auf der wir
uns ausruhen
sollten die EU hat im Sommer einen
sogenannten ai Act verabschiedet der
könnte dann in zwei Jahren in Kraft
treten das Gesetz sieht vor dass KI
Anwendung in bestimmte Risikoklassen
unterteilt werden und dann je nach Höhe
des Risikos dann eben auch die
entsprechende
Regulierung passieren soll wie für wie
sinnvoll halten Sie diesen
Schritt da sind viele sinnvolle Gedanken
dahinter ein paar Sachen habe ich
kritisiert und eines davon dass wir
Basistechnologie regulieren wollen das
haben wir noch nie so gemacht bisher
hatten wir immer anhand der Anwendung
also klar für Medizingeräte gibt's eine
harte Regulierung wie für viele andere
Dinge auch für Produkthaftung wir haben
hier zum ersten Mal gesagt wir wollen KI
als Basistechnologie völlig unabhängig
von der Anwendung eventuell regulieren
und das ist kritisch zu betrachten aus
meiner Sicht das wäre so ein bisschen
als hätten wir bei der Erfindung des
Computers gesagt so ein Computer ist ja
sehr komplex man kann ja viel damit
machen auch viel Negatives damit machen
deswegen regulieren wir jetzt jeden
Computer egal wo er steht ja das ist
Gott se danke nicht so
passiert darüber hinaus ist es so dass
das jetzt auch nichts Neues was nur bei
KI so ist Regulierung hilft immer den
großen den etablierten Unternehmen und
dass wir hier als wenn man sich die
globalen Machtblöcke anschaut hinten
hinter den USA und hinter China auf
einem dritten Platz sind und dann die
ganze kreative Energie die ganze die
ganzen Ideen die wir haben die wir für
Innovation bräuchten dass wir viel davon
jetzt gerade umlenken auf Compliance auf
Regeln ja bevor wir überhaupt die
Innovation gemacht haben das halte ich
auch für sehr bedenklich ich würd es
gern andersrum machen dass wir erstmal
Innovation machen und dann überlegen wie
wir das ganze regulieren denn wenn wir
jetzt nicht
mit den richtigen Ideen mit den
richtigen Menschen ins ins Laufen kommen
dann werden wir überhaupt keine Hand am
Lenkrad haben dann werden wir nur noch
entscheiden können ob wir Kunde bei den
USA oder Kunde bei China werden Herr
androdis dazu passt auch noch gut eine
Frage die wir bei Youtube bekommen haben
von SMI SM und zwar welche Maßnahmen bzw
Initiativen sie haben es gerade schon
kurz angerissen würden sie sich von
staatlicher Seite wünschen um den KI
standandort um dem kistandort
Deutschland zu
helfen
also da zurück zu quasi meinem Punkt
oder auch was der Ministerpräsident
gesagt hat Forschung sind wir eigentlich
gut aufgestellt bei der Forschung müssen
wir jetzt nur schauen dass wir diese
Konzentration die notwendig wird helfen
also es war so früher konnte man KI
konnte jeder doktorant KI mit einem
kleinen Computer mit einer Grafikkarte
drin machen was wir jetzt halt brauchen
sind riesige Cluster mit Spezialwissen
mit Menschen die diese Kluster managen
das heißt wir brauchen hier eine ganz
neue unterstütz wie wir unsere
Spitzenforscher unterstützen können auf
der Industrieseite müssen wir einfach
die Technologie in die Anwendung bringen
das was BadenWürttemberg mit dem
Staatsministerium mit F13 macht ist ein
super Beispiel sicherlich eine der oder
meines Wissens nach die innovativste
Anwendung von generativer KI in der
Verwaltung weltweit aber das ganze muss
natürlich auch in die Breite in den
Mittelstand in die in
die innovativsten industrieplayer der
Welt reingehen also da müssen wir
einfach schauen wie können diese
Technologie auf die Straße bringen wie
kann eventuell die Regierung wie kann
der Staat dabei helfen dass es
Unternehmen leichter fällt die
Technologie anzuwenden und da ist
natürlich gerade so eine Regulierung die
auch so eine Menge Unsicherheit mit sich
bringt nicht unbedingt die beste Idee
mhm sie haben die Person gerade kurz
angesprochen die es neben der
Technologie natürlich braucht dazu passt
noch eine andere Frage von YouTube und
zwar sollte Deutschland versuchen
Fachkräfte aus den USA abzuwerben um die
Innovation hier zu beschleunigen
das machen wir ja also ich bin ja eine
Fachkraft aus den USA wenn man so will
aus wier zurü genau richtig aus der
kiforschung wir haben aber auch bei uns
im Unternehmen haben wir Menschen auch
von Microsoft Research von Google von
Google brain aus den USA nach Heidelberg
geholt das geht also das kriegen wir hin
weil wir halt eben hier diese Projekte
haben das wichtigste für diese für die
Toptalente ist sie wollen mit tollen
Menschen mit inspirierenden Menschen
arbeiten und sie wollen an den Projekt
arbeiten die wirklich die Welt verändern
und dass diesen Rahmen haben wir hier
für Alif Alpha für die kiforschung
geschaffen und wir sehen dass wir
Bewerbungen überall aus der Welt
bekommen auch aus den USA also das ist
überhaupt kein Problem wir müssen jetzt
eben nur damit das nachhaltig
stabilisiert werden kann müssen wir
diese Technologie einsetzen
weiterentwickeln wir müssen weiter
Partnerschaften
aufbauen mhm Herr Andris lassen Sie uns
gerne abschließend noch einmal würde ich
ih gerne noch einmal eine Frage weiter
geben und zwar es es wird ja immer viel
darüber diskutiert wo wir KI tatsächlich
einsetzen sollten wie weit sie gehen
darf welche Kompetenzen sie haben darf
und welche Regulierung es dann auch
geben sollte haben wir auch drüber
gesprochen wie ist ihre Auffassung da
als jemand der das in Deutschland
maßgeblich vorantreibt welche Aufgaben
sollte KI in Zukunft übernehmen und wo
sollte sie ganz klar ihre Grenzen haben
was sollte weiter in sozusagen
menschlicher Hand dann bleiben
was man immer beachten muss KI ist ein
Werkzeug also KI hat keine eigene
Meinung KI kann nicht lügen weil die KI
eben gar kein Konzept hat von Wahrheit
wo wir überzeugt sind ist dass
Verantwortung egal wie gut KI in Zukunft
wird Verantwortung kann nur der Mensch
übernehmen der Mensch unsere Kunden
Menschen im Privatmenschen müssen
entscheiden für was setze ich wie KI ein
und dabei Verantwortung übernehmen und
das ist eines der großen Unterschiede
auch von unserer Technologie denn so ein
Chatbot der einfach irgendeine Antwort
gibt und man kann gar nicht
nachvollziehen wo kommt diese Antwort
her gibt's da vielleicht noch andere
möglichen Antworten und wie stehen die
im im Bezug zu irgendwchen anderen
wissen was es in der Welt gibt das ist
eine Situation in der ich quasi keine
Verantwortung übernehmen kann ich kann
einfach nur sagen ja kommt für Microsoft
wird schon stimmen ja und das ist nicht
ausreichend das heißt wir sind überzeugt
dass egal wie gut KI wird die
Verantwortung gehört zu Menschen und die
KI muss so gebaut sein dass sie
transparent und steuerbar
ist sagt Jonas andrulis der CEO und
Gründer von Alef Alpha danke schön für
ihre Zeit heute Abend und für die ganzen
Antworten danke schön schönen Abend
Ihnen auch vielen Dank also 500
Millionen Dollar für Alf Alpha das ist
natürlich eine Menge Geld aber ein Blick
auf die anderen Investitionen in
kiunternehmen der lässt diese Zahl dann
doch verhältnismäßig klein aussiehen auf
dem ersten Platz in einem Ranking wir
haben es im Beitrag auch schon kurz
gesehen und sehen die Grafik jetzt hier
noch mal landet open ai alleine in einer
Finanzierungsrunde hat das Startup 10
Milliarden Dollar eingesammelt
Deutschland landet mit Alf Alpha dessen
CEO ich gerade im Gespräch hatte in
diesem Platz auf Platz in diesem Ranking
auf Platz 10 wir wollen jetzt noch
einmal weiter vertiefen und darüber
sprechen wie der KI standandort
Deutschland also besser und attraktiver
werden kann und darüber kann ich jetzt
sprechen mit Professorin Ulrike
Malmendier sie ist Ökonomin lehrt an der
University of California in Berkeley und
berätt als Wirtschaftsweise auch die
deutsche Bundesregierung guten Abend aus
Mainz und guten Morgen nach
Kalifornien hallo sehr und ebenfalls
zugeschaltet ist uns Professor Marcel
fratcher er ist der Chef des des
Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft so
ist es richtig hallo her fratcher grüße
sie guten Abend war nicht richtig
deutsches Institut für Wirtschaft
Forschung ist ein wichtiger Unterschied
aber ist okay Entschuldigung
Entschuldigung dann nehmen wir diese
Korrektur an dieser Stelle gerne
entgegen so und jetzt haben wir es
richtig gestellt vielen Dank also die
erste Frage gerne an Frau Malmendier in
Alif Alpha setzen hier zu Lande viele
große Hoffnung sie auch
ähm ja also für mich ist die Hoffnung
gibt es zwei Aspekte zum einen einfach
der Bereich KI insgesamt der in allen
Bereichen immer wichtiger wird jetzt
nicht nur
in diesen l language Models die wir alle
mit Chat GPT kennengelernt haben egal
welchen Industriezweig sie sich angucken
wo sie Startups angucken für
produktionsmechanismen Verwaltung oder
Frau dir darf ich sie einmal ganz
entschuldigung darf ich sie einmal ganz
kurz unterbrechen weil wir hören Sie
leider nur sehr leise haben Sie die
Möglichkeit da noch ein bisschen näher
ans Mikrofon heranzugehen das wäre toll
tut mir leicht vorhin war der Sound okay
und das Licht war glaube ich auch was
besser ist das jetzt ein bisschen besser
geworden okay es ist glaube ich jetzt
ein mü besser so das wäre nur wichtig
weil wir natürlich gerne verstehen
wollen was sie sagen ja ja tut mir leid
dass jetzt mein Gesicht in solcher
Übergröße haben aber ich hoffe man
versteht mich jetzt ein bisschen
besser ist das KI sowohl für alle
Industrien sehr wichtig ist nicht nur
für die large language Models die Chat
gpts die wir sehen sondern ob sie sich
produzierende Gewerbe angucken ob sie
sich bi anschauen insofern ist es sehr
wichtig dass Deutschland da vertreten
ist der andere Aspekt ist dass mir
Hoffnung gibt was insgesamt
kapitalmarktbasierte Finanzierung
betrifft die 500 Millionen spätunden
Finanzierung mögen ihn kleinercheinen im
Ranking im Vergleich zu Open ai aber da
haben wir es endlich mal geschafft über
die initial seed funding Startup funding
Runde hinauszukommen ohne staatliche
Kofinanzierung große Industriegruppen
Unternehmen zu
und das gibt mir sehr viel Hoffnung was
die Wachstumsmöglichkeiten für
Deutschland in innovativen Bereichen
betrifft soweit ihre Einschätzung ich
würde die Frage auch gerne noch einmal
weitergeben an Herrn fratcher jetzt
jetzt mache ich es richtig herr fratcher
Präsident des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung teilen Sie diesen
Optimismus ich teile ihn begrenzt denn
ich glaube wir haben in Deutschland
immer noch nicht
erkannt dass ist für uns kein eine
Option ist ähm ob wir jetzt Teil davon
werden oder nicht und viele denken wir
haben doch die Industrie wir haben doch
die Automobilwirtschaft wir haben doch
tolle Maschinenbau und Chemie aber wir
müssen verstehen dass ähm das Auto der
Zukunft zu 90% aus Software besteht und
künstliche Intelligenz beispielsweise
für das autonome fahren essenziell
wichtig ist also es ist keine Option für
uns dabei zu sein sondern ein Muss und
das zweite was mir Sorge macht ist die
Regulierung wir haben in Europa ähm sehr
ambitionierte Regulierung Standards das
ist aus vielerlei Hinsicht gut wir
wollen
Persönlichkeitsrechte schützen wir
wollen keine Diskriminierung wir wollen
so etwas wie Social scoring in China wo
im Prinzip der Mensch ein gläserer
Mensch ist sowas wollen wir nicht aber
wenn man Innovation macht und das ist ja
eben auch in dem Beitrag angeklungen
dann müssen wir überlegen wie wir global
gemeinsame Standards entwickeln dass
eben auch Innovation in Deutschland
Europa entstehen kann ohne dass die
Regulierung ist es bremst also
Regulierung ist gut aber wir brauchen
eben gemeinsame Standards deshalb habe
ich da Bauchschmerzen dass wir manchmal
üers Ziel hinausschießen mit der
Regulierung wer ist denn da für sie
maßgeblich gerade in der Verantwortung
also wo haakt es ihre Einschätzung nach
aktuell meiner Ansicht nach müssen wir
erstmal in Deutschland verstehen dass
wir eine europäische Strategie brauchen
das viel dieser Technologien was mit
Marktgröße zu tun haben auch bei der
finanzi
das heißt wir müssen erstmal europäisch
denken wir brauchen eine europäische
Strategie viel stärker klar wir haben
die Regulierung
den Act der Europäischen Kommission wir
brauchen z.B eine kapitalmarktunion in
Europa dass Finanzierung auch über
private überhaupt möglich wird also wir
müssen hier primär europäisch denken und
ich denke wir sind da immer noch zu sehr
in unserem nationaldenken verhaftet das
ist für mich eins der zentralen
Probleme ich würde gerne noch einmal
Frau an Sie die Frage richten welche
Bedeutung hat wenn wir nach vorne
schauen und auch einmal in dem Moment
jetzt also welche Bedeutung hat
künstliche Intelligenz für die deutsche
Wirtschaft aktuell und welchen
Stellenwert wird sie in Zukunft da noch
kriegen zunächst mal müssen wir da
glaube ich gar nicht groß zwischen
deutscher Wirtschaft und Herr fratcher
sprach europäische Wirtschaft oder soar
globale Wirtschaft an die AI hat enormes
Potential Arbeitsprozesse zu
beschleunigen vor allen Dingen im
Verwaltungsbereich der angesprochen wird
Dinge zu vereinfachen schneller
vorzugehen und einfach auch Lösungen zu
finden ich sprach von Biotechnologie an
wenn man nach neuen Kombinationen von
Molekülen sucht etc also man kann sich
wirklich jeden Bereich aussuchen man
sieht im Prinzip im Augenblick überhaupt
keine
firmenneugründung wo ai keine Rolle
spielt in Deutschland insbesondere gibt
es mehrere Aspekte die Herr andrules
eigentlich alle hervorragend
angesprochen hat in dem Interview vorher
es gibt den Bereich
Arbeitskräfte wir haben in Deutschland
Arbeitskräftemangel Fachkräftemangel und
Arbeitskräftemangel im weiteren Sinne
das heißt da die Hoffnung äh zu ersetzen
aber auch als Standort attraktiv zu
werden und zusätzliche Fachkräfte
anzulocken die vielleicht nicht für
jeden Job nach Deutschland kämen aber
für so etwas Spannendes wie im
ki-bereich zu arbeiten vielleicht doch
nach Deutschland kämen ist die Nummer
eins das zweite ist seit Jahren und
Jahrzehnten sprechen wir davon dass wir
Entbürokratisierung brauchen
dass wir Prozesse Verwaltungsprozesse
vereinfachen müssen auch hier kann KI
wenn richtig angesetzt
deutlich helfen da Fortschritte zu
machen
endlich in Verbindung mit der
Digitalisierung die wir ja schon so
lange in Deutschland haben möchten und
drittens möchte ich noch einmal betonen
dass wir hier in Deutschland im
Augenblick
auf einem wachstumsfahrt sind der nicht
besonders vielversprechend ist das
sogenannte Potenzialwachstum die
mittelfristigen Aussichten sind aberim
historischen Tiefstand und um da wieder
rauszukommen müssen wir ganz unabhängig
von coronakrise
Energiekrise das hat diesen aktuellen
konjunkturschwankung wirklich nicht zu
tun müssen wir unabhängig davon neue
Wachstumsbereiche finden wo wir die die
Wachstumszahlen die sich die Regierung
und sicherlich die Bevölkerung wünschen
würde wieder erreichen könnte und da hat
künstliche Intelligenz natürlich enormes
Potenzial uns zu solchen innovativen
Bereichen zu verhelfen Frau me die
vorige Bundesregierung hat im November
2018 die sogenannte KI Strategie
beschlossen bis 2025 sollen insgesamt 5
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung gestellt
werden von von der Bundesregierung
damals hieß es die KI sei eine der
wichtigsten Schlüssel
Schlüsseltechnologien als
Wirtschaftsweise beraten Sie die
aktuelle Bundesregierung was tut die
ihrer Einschätzung nach aktuell um
diesem Ziel gerecht zu werden
also die Bundesregierung ist sich
wirklich äh sehr bewusst der Rolle die
KI spielen kann das kommt in fast jedem
unserer Gespräche vor ich weiß auch dass
sehr eng verfolgt wurde wie das mit der
Wachstumsfinanzierung z.B für Alif Alpha
im im Augenblick aussieht ähm was ich
mir wünschen würde ähm das bindet auch
an den Kommentar von Herr fratcher an
ist dass wir auf der regulierungsseite
es schaffen für diese Unternehmen
Produkte zu kreieren die sowohl
sicher sind koordiniert mit europäischen
Partnern aber auch keine unnötigen
Hürden in den Weg legen da sind z.B oft
äh
Datenschutzgesetze nicht modernisiert
das heißt nicht dass sie weniger äh
sicher sein sollen sondern das einfach
möglich sein soll Daten zu nutzen um in
der Forschung einschließlich der
kforschung Fortschritte zu machen ähm
Herr andules sprach an dass z.B mit
diesem Wechsel von Sam Altman nach
Microsoft die einzige Hörde die er haben
könnte die ist dass jetzt z.B gewisse
Datenmassen nicht zur Verfügung hat
solange wir da nach wie vor hohe Hörden
aufbauen was die Datenverfügbarkeit was
die Datenerhebung betrifft werden wir
auch in diesem ki-bereich der halt große
Datenmassen benötigt ähm weiter eine
Hörde haben aber ich weiß daran wird
gearbeitet mhm Herr fratcher es gibt
eine aktuelle Meldung von heute und zwar
investiert der Bund gemeinsam mit
Blackrock Allianz und anderen
Versicherern eine Milliarde Euro in
Startups davon sollen dann auch gezielt
KI Startups profitieren ist das das ein
richtiges Signal in die deutsche
Wirtschaft speziell auch als für den für
den KI standandort
Deutschland ja es ist ein ganz wichtiges
Signal auch der wachstumsfond den die KF
jetzt auflegt
das ist das ist schon etwas wo man sagt
das ist ein erster Schritt das ein
kleine Summen das sind nicht das was man
langfristig benötigt aber es geht ja
darum dass man im Prinzip einen Impuls
setzt das weiteres privates Kapital
mobilisiert der Staat alleine kann das
nicht und sollte es auch nicht versuchen
selber jetzt auszuwählen wo die Gelder
hinfließen aber diese
diese Unterstützung ein Markt zu
schaffen ein Impuls zu geben um damit
privates Kapital zu mobilisieren ist es
essentiell übrigens brauchen wir dafür
auch eine Veränderung der Regulierung im
Bereich Kapitalmärkte dass es
beispielsweise für für Pensionsfonds
leichter wird Kapital nicht nur in
Staatsanleihen investieren zu müssen
weil es regulatorisch so vorgeschrieben
ist sondern auch stärker ins Risiko zu
gehen und da brauchen wir auch in
Deutschland eine neue Mentalität ähm
neue Einstellung zum Thema Risiko in
Startups investieren heißt in vielen
Fällen dass vier von fünf dieser
Investitionen scheitern werden aber wenn
eine von fünf oder eine von se
durchkommen was dann der der große
Erfolg sein wird dann hat sich diese
Investition gelohnt also wir brauchen
auch da eine neue Mentalität was
Risikokapital betrifft und auch im
Bereich Kapitalmarkt muss die
Regulierung modernisiert werden jetzt
wurde ja in der Debatte um künstliche
Intelligenz und wie weit man diese
einsetzen soll auch immer wieder darüber
gesprochen dass dadurch möglicherweise
auch Arbeitsplätze gefährdet sind eine
Frage die wir bei Youtube bekommen haben
geht in die andere Richtung und zwar
eröffnen sich dadurch möglicherweise
auch neue wirtsch szweige Herr
frcher ja natürlich erstens mal zum zum
Verlust von Arbeitsplätzen das ist
natürlich so wir werden auch übrigens so
typische Mittel stiicht Job gut bezahlte
Arbeitsplätze in den
Rechtsanwaltskanzleien die Recherche
machen werden dadurch verschwinden gehen
wenn irgendwann das autonome fahren
kommt werden viele
Lkwfahrer nicht mehr die Tätigkeit haben
und wir haben dürfen nicht vergessen
Deutschland hat heute ein fachkräfteprem
ein Arbeits kräfteprem also äh das
stellt die deutsche Wirtschaft vor eine
große Herausforderung das heißt nicht
Arbeit Massenarbeitslosigkeit sondern
wir brauchen mehr
Flexibilisierung Menschen müssen in
neuen Bereichen Arbeitsplätze finden und
es ist eben auch eine riesige Chance wie
sie zurecht beschreiben hier werden neue
Berufsfelder entstehen neue äh
Wachstumsbranchen entstehen ähm ich
glaube wir dürfen uns in Deutschland
Europa auch nicht zu klein machen wir
haben es eben bei hern rudes gehört
völlig zurecht wir haben viele kluge
Köpfe Talente in Europa gerade in
Deutschland das ist eine der großen
Stärken und das als Chance zu verstehen
nicht nur als Bedrohung ist wichtig
ähm und ich glaub wir würden gut daran
tun sowohl in der Wissenschaft aber vor
allem auch in der Politik ein bisschen
mehr auf diese startupunternehmen zu
hören nicht nur versuchen das bestehende
das alte zu zementieren das ist was die
Wirtschaftspolitik meiner Ansicht nach
heute zu sehr tut indem sie Milliarden
Subventionen an die alte Industrie
schiebt sondern wir brauchen einen viel
stärkeren Fokus auf neu Ideen auf
Innovation auf junge Unternehmen und da
würde ich mir Umdenken gerade in der
deutschen Politik wünschen klarer Appell
von Herrn fratcher Frau Mar dir
abschließend an sie noch mal die Frage
wir haben es in diesem Stream jetzt auch
immer wieder angerissen aber auf welche
ja ganz grundlegenden Veränderung müssen
wir uns alle denn vielleicht durch die
KI in den kommenden Jahren jetzt
einstellen aus ihrer
Sicht so in den konkreten Auswirkung in
den verschiedenen Industriezweigen ist
das meines Erachtens noch nicht
abschätzbar
wofür diese Revolution durch künstliche
Intelligenz aber steht ist genau dieses
Thema dass neue zukunftsorientierte
Unternehmen einmal eine im eine immer
größer werdende Rolle spielen und
spielen müssen wenn wir in Deutschland
wieder Wachstum haben werden das heißt
es muss einen Wandel geben in
Deutschland das
Kapitalmarktorientierung Finanzierung
von neuen innovativen Ideen vom
Kapitalmarkt aus eine sehr viel
wichtigere Rolle spielt als bisher wir
können nicht weiter nur auf die
traditionellen Industrien brauchen die
der bauen die der Wachstumsmotor in
Deutschland waren Maschinenbau Automobil
Chemie die sind weiter extrem wichtig
und in haben auch Innovation was
hervorragend ist aber es wird ganz neue
Bereiche geben nicht nur KI ich würde
ganz explizit sagen auch so etwas wie
BioScience eine größere Rolle spielen
dafür steht die KI meinesachtens und das
wird einhergehen nicht nur mit einer
Änderung der Einstellung der
Wirtschaftspolitik die Herr fratcha
vorhin angesprochen hat die ich
g auch sehr
begrüßen würde wenn das eintritt aber
auch in der weiteren Bevölkerung
Verständnis dafür wie wichtig
startupkultur ist wie interessant und
wichtig Kapitalmärkte sind da schon im
Schüleralter anzufangen und das durch
das arbeitslebenindurch in der
Bevölkerung einzubauen diesen Wandel
brauchen wir im Augenblick und ich denke
KI ist da ganz hervorragend durch diese
Produkte wie z.B chatgpt in die weitere
Bevölkerung gebracht ähm dass dass das
dann auch bei uns allen ankommt
Ulrike Malm dir vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung heute abend toll dass wir
sie in Kalifornien erreichen konnten und
danke auch an Marcel fratcher ich sag's
jetzt zum Abschluss noch einmal richtig
Präsident des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung danke ihnen beiden
einen schönen Abend danke schön ja
soweit unser ZDF heute live zur
künstlichen Intelligenz made in Germany
wenn ihr aktuelle Infos haben möchtet
z.B auch zur digitalkonferenz zum
digital Gipfel der Bundesregierung in
Jena dann schaut gerne vorbei bei uns in
der ZDF heute App danke für eure Fragen
danke fürs mitdiskutieren und bis zum
nächsten
Mal